As you are modernizing your enterprise, how do you mitigate the risks
and vulnerabilities associated with transitioning into a container architecture?
Hi, my name is Charles and I'm a Cloud Developer here with IBM Cloud.
Today, I'm going to give you a general overview
and an introduction to how you can begin
to secure your container environment.
Let's say that you're an enterprise and
you're using VMs to host your application code
and you want to transition
into using containers.
Containers are really great
because they allow you
to smoothen the application development pipeline
and they can be deployed just about anywhere.
However, because of this flexibility of
being able to deploy just about anywhere,
a whole new variety of attack services
exist surrounding the container environment.
Some of these include the images that you use
to build your containers; the image registries
that we use to store our images
in; the container run times
which we use to execute our containers.
And, the orchestration platforms which we use
to manage the lifecycle of
multiple containers with.
And lastly, the host OS which manages the Docker
client and the Docker daemon and the kernel
of which is shared with our
running Docker containers.
So, when we look at images as a potential
vulnerability, one of the best things
that we can do to address this
vulnerability is to make sure
that we're keeping our images up to date.
And the reason this is so
important is because images that are
up to date typically have the latest
security patches which protect you
from the latest vulnerabilities that they track.
We also want to make sure that we're regularly
scanning our images so that we can keep track
of any new vulnerabilities that
may not have already been caught.
And we also want to make sure
that we're signing our images.
And signing an image will essentially create
a digital fingerprint that you can use
to cryptographically test
and verify whoever it was
that was trying to manipulate the image with.
Now, image registries are a potential
vulnerability, because they contain all
of these images which contain
your application code.
And so in order to keep them
secure, you want to make sure
that you're keeping your image registries
private and a private registry really is one
that gives you absolute control over
the types of images, how many images
and the access control of the users
that are accessing the registry.
You also want to make sure that you're
regularly monitoring your registry
so that you can track any vulnerabilities
that may come about, and you want to make sure
that the host server for the registry
is secure so that you can protect it
from being compromised and
you can protect your images
and the application code from being accessed.
When it comes to the container run time,
run times can be a little bit tricky
because historically security tools related
to containers monitor more the communication
around them rather than what's happening inside.
So, one of the best things you can do is to
make sure that you're app security is up to par
and you also want to make sure that you
are monitoring your network protocols
and your network payloads.
You also want to make sure that
you're monitoring the host as well.
When it comes to orchestration
softwares, these are platforms
such as Kubernetes or container
platforms like OCP.
And what's great about these is that they
include lots of access control capabilities
which means that you can easily set limits
not just on the number of privileged users
that you have -- which is
an important thing to do --
but also the amount of privilege that you give
any one user so that if the user is compromised,
they're not able to attack your
entire orchestration platform.
You also want to make sure that you are
monitoring your orchestration platform as well.
And that you're monitoring the pod
communication within the orchestration platform.
When it comes to the host OS, this is
potentially one of the greatest vulnerabilities
that you can have in your container
environment because the host OS
if compromised will give the
attacker essentially access
to your entire application environment.
So, in order to help to mitigate
this, it's good to have a slim OS,
something like SE Linux is a great option.
You also want to make sure that you have access
control implemented within your OS and you want
to make sure that you're also
regularly monitoring the OS as well
for any vulnerabilities to
protect it from being compromised.
And so these are the a few of the
potential vulnerabilities that exist
in the space surrounding your container.
When it comes to protecting the container
itself, there's a lot of great open source tools
that exist and one of them falls
under the category of scanning.
It's sort of the de facto option
when it comes to scanning tools
for containers and it's called Docker Bench.
And Docker Bench is great because it's
really just a simple script that runs
and it will test your container against dozens
of different container production
deployment best practices,
and it will let you know how
your container does against it.
Open Scap is another great option which it sort
of will collect and analyze different...oh,
sorry, it will allow you to create schedules
around continuous scanning for your container.
Now, when it comes to monitoring tools, a
really great option is called Prometheus,
and Prometheus is great because
this one will allow you to collect
and analyze different metrics around
communication between different node end points.
Lastly, when it comes to firewall tools, Cilium
is a fantastic option because it will allow you
to analyze communication in your
network and also the communication
between all the different
application services that you have.
So, just to recap.
We've gone over a few of the
vulnerabilities that exist in the environment
around the container and then we've gone
over some really great open source tools
that can help to secure your container.
Thank you.
If you have questions, please
drop us a line below.
If you want to see more videos like this
in the future, please like and subscribe.
And don't forget, you can grow your skills and
earn a badge with IBM Cloud Labs which are free,
browser based, interactive Kubernetes labs.